hey you guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Jerry today we're gonna check out the
trailer for the 33 I think there's a
there yeah the 33 antonio banderas
rodrigo santoro sexiest story of men
trapped in a cape yeah sexy minor sexy
minors my mine me RS not not sexy young
kids oh yeah I know I mean that would be
way too much CG yeah Antonio Banderas is
getting older you lovebirds get the
sonogram yet boy congratulations on your
retirement two weeks and you're a friend
is that the only way in the only way the
only way out
Kobus longer over an hour we may be
looking at a weakness in the mountains
internal structure she's an old mine is
my job to keep this message
[Music]
Jesus yes
mine perhaps a serious accident just
occurred at the San Jose mine like no
one would necessarily something I'm
giving that's a big broke that's not a
rock that's the heart of the month she
find any problem no 33 men trapped
underground and we don't even know if
they're alive
that's the worst Irish or this man yeah
there's for the water for three days I
knew this place was dangerous
nobody's ready you you are my brother we
gotta put together to get out of here
three platforms are now in place
specialized in deep drilling Phil a
bleep enemy a huge rock twice the size
of the Empire State Building wrong the
Iranian of time it's not a question of
if it falls but when I'm not leaving
without him
if that is our last supper I quit
[Music]
last thing we need is these men dying
with the whole world watching 33 men in
the ground 300 mothers fathers brothers
sisters and we're their only hope let's
get ourselves from miner say something
see you old men out there riggan J can
you feel this
I don't want to do I want to do you know
what it is yeah what is it no it's a
nipple chill oh that I should get
checked out that looks like a moving
tail but it might be a little corny and
cliche well I feel like it only looks
the the potential corniness just comes
from the choice of that song like say
something this song isn't from a mining
movie about a mine disaster this song is
for likes okay that's on our stars yes I
like that like like a romance or
Nicholas Berg who was that Chloe grace
Moretz movie where she was like dead but
not dead dead but not dead she like
played the cello or something yeah if I
stay yeah that's what that was last time
I heard that song I was like I get the
mood is appropriate with the lyrics
alright I gotta say though and Tonio
Banderas looks very good oh yeah it
looks great you know he has that passion
still yeah how cool that Daris is when
it's nice to see you know a movie with a
predominantly Hispanic cast yeah I like
the show East Lowe's high on Hulu but
significantly more mature and probably
better possibly it's just about a whole
different situation and it's cool seeing
rodrigo santoro in this role because
he's normally kind of in like action
films that were something he's rarely in
like a really good drama that's really
being promoted like Warner Brothers is a
big studio and this is a drama and
rodrigo santoro is one of the
people in this film it's cool to see
them really pushing him for a dramatic
role well I feel like it's the kind of
thing where it's like I don't know his
career super well so I feel like we only
see him on a wide scale when he's in
something like 300 or the last stay now
I feel like he's probably done a lot
more work than we know about you Love
Actually hey I love that movie so my
favorite movies agree disagree that's
great the way it's shot looks pretty
cool that mining accident look I hope it
doesn't go to CG you know like there's
some obvious CGI there like with a car
flip in and [ __ ] I'm on the car flip the
frame no you're dumb right there okay
yeah sure that's fine just wrap prove
your point it was so quick I didn't even
think about that incident could be
really powerful if it the more real it
looks because that was scary when
they're showing the craziness going on
and then it cuts to outside and you're
like oh it's just like dust yeah yeah
well I mean it's it's a it's fortunate I
mean for the for the technical side of
things that this should be in a mind
because you know you can cover you can
make CGI look better in dustier and
darker environments oh yeah you know the
less you have to worry about direct
light you know and clarity the better I
hope this movie goes all out with the
psychological stress it could take on a
character this is basically the third
sequel to the descent these men are
trapped under there for like you know
three days I think or two a week
something like that I don't know the
actual story yeah but they're trapped
under there and it would be interesting
like there was this one moment where a
guy was making a joke about quitting if
this is his last supper and they were
all laughing and I was like that's not
really a funny joke but they're all
laughing because they're probably all
really malnourished and fatigued just
going a little delirious right now and I
want to explore that actually I would
love to seed like cuz it looks like
there will be a journey of like real
struggle and like people breaking down
especially Antonia Maris's character
yeah I mean it seems like you'll have
the two halves they'll have you know the
people on the outside trying to do
something about this but I gotta imagine
a heavy portion of this will be just the
psychological toll it takes on the dudes
actually in the situation exactly Bob
Gunton
I was playing the president I think what
he's a good actor me yeah like I that
just does not seem like smart casting
there to me I've seen him in stuff that
I've liked him in III wonder if maybe it
just cuts bad for a trailer that seems
like an accent very or deliberate
casting choice yeah then I don't I don't
know that accent was just not good
it was really bad accent yeah or well or
it appeared that way maybe it's the kind
of thing where you actually have to hear
it you know we don't even know if there
are alive he's like Liam Neeson trying
to do a Spanish that's like I almost
don't believe that it would still be
this way they'd have looped it or
something if it was truly that bad so
I'd be surprised if it was that bad in
the finished product
you'd be surprised that would be
surprised you'd be surprised at how dumb
Hollywood is sometimes you feel like a
Hollywood like it is this is summer
blockbuster at its best right now yeah
in November height of the summer season
yeah I know then around June July is
when Oscar movies ya know the Oscar push
starts in January oh yeah that's what a
real cinema
yeah usually peaks at that point anyway
guys thanks for tuning into the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
reasons to Gerry and dank ass Stubbs on
this channel you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter or vine and
Paris go babe
Shawn Dodds yeah hey Ryan plus one
reactor that's you Oh plus one right now
love your [ __ ] my [ __ ] is pretty funny
hilarious I want you in the black Viking
that is a Tyrone magnesite to have a
beautiful chocolate baby we would have
to adopt want to do a surrogate maybe we
can combine our sperm kinda like when
Neil Patrick Harris did you could do
that thing like in them oral sores a
movie how did you yeah yeah I don't know
Danny DeVito is a whole new level of
mastermind found you guys to the black
Viking Tyrone Magnus and I've been
addicted to you and the other react
astok for you make my day especially
Ryan with all your dick jokes and sexual
innuendos I think it's the first time
that phrase has ever been uttered that
way just like your your dick jokes
really make my day
are you kidding I get that all the time
really dick joke specifically the number
one compliment is Ryan keep up the dick
jokes that's a sad truth and I live -
keep doing what you're doing I think you
guys are awesome Sean dogs dude I would
love to dogs earbuds
dodds is you know know now the pressures
on me good yeah all right we found a
real life photo of you he's licking cold
ice cream he's looking like our gold and
ice cream of a flight Kirby okay look
I'm gonna give you my honest belief I'm
the kind of person you look like to me
person who's attracted to minors am I
gonna clear that up saying minors as in
people who mine or as in people who
don't mind a minor it's up to you man
why don't mind a minor was it even me
you know like don't mind a minor Oh mind
like they wouldn't mind having a minor
in Sean dogs or why is it okay still
it's so terrible you look like you could
be attracted to little kids no you don't
or you look like you could be attracted
to people who work in a mind terrible
well okay I mean
whatever floats your boat as long as
it's not harmful yeah